- Never in the past, in the history,
except during second World War,
have we had so many, have
we not had so many refugees,
65 million refugees now.
The United Nations has to feed every day,
at least 135 million people.
Every day, breakfast, lunch and dinner.
- [Man] How many does
the United Nations feed?
How many?
- 135 million.
- [Man] That's what the UN feeds everyday?
- Yes, including 65 million refugees.
We need to mobilize huge resources.
The more refugees the more problems.
I think the less humanitarian support
come from international community.
That's very troubling.
That is why people are complaining
against the United Nation.
At this time, I count
on the United States.
United State is by any
standard, by any standard,
the most important, most resourceful,
most powerful country in the world.
And continues engagement
and global leadership
of the United States is crucial
to make United Nations
united and deliverable.